eu vim hoje aqui contar pra vocês uma
história uma história que mostra um
caminho de busca pela integração
integração de mente corpo e integração
de ocidente oriente integração de menina
e mulher integração de masculino e
feminino
desde muito pequena eu tive uma presença
masculina muito forte na minha vida que
a presença do meu pai
todo primeiro domingo do mês a gente
visitava a livraria era um programa do
mesmo o que eu mais esperava ele me
levava pra livraria para a gente comprar
livros era de fato o momento mais
esperado da minha vida e para a livraria
com o meu pai tanto que ele fala até
hoje diz comigo lembra quando a gente ia
edições paulinas e e e é um momento de
muito amor porque é claro que ganhar
presente é muito legal mas eu acho que
desde muito cedo na minha vida ficou
associada à imagem do masculino e do
conhecimento com amor porque era naquele
momento que a gente se reunia naquela
sutilezas daquele presente em que eu
sentia tanta alegria me sentia tão tão
realizada também em outro momento de
sutilezas a minha infância quando eu
tinha 3 anos e foi em 1987 foi a morte
do presidente tancredo neves
é eu tinha três anos mas a minha mãe
conta que eu pegava minha escova de
cabelo que ficava em frente à televisão
narrando a morte do tancredo como se eu
fosse uma repórter com um link ao vivo
então eu acho que essa percepção da
minha mãe essa sutileza também da minha
mãe de perceber como aquela criança que
brincava na frente das câmeras é poderia
um dia se tornar jornalista explicou
presente na minha vida ao longo dos anos
desde pequeno gostava muito da magia
gostava muito de me fantasiar e meu pai
comprava fantasia de heroína de imaginar
como se eu fosse a protagonista da
história como se eu fosse aquela heroína
que passava por todas aquelas aventuras
que eu imaginava na minha cabeça isso
era muito forte pra mim essa magia mesmo
a minha vida sempre foi muito mágica eu
entrei no colégio de freira logo quando
eu tinha por volta dos meus 9 10
anos e admirava tanto a figura daquelas
mulheres que vestiam aquelas fantasias o
que estava por trás daquilo eu sempre me
xingou as fantasias que a gente usa para
poder revelar que nós realmente somos
porque eu sempre gostei de usar muitas
fantasias e já passando pelos meus 15
anos de uma prima minha que tinha
acabado de ir para os estados unidos a
morar em nova york que ocupam a maior
mudança esse presente de 15 anos meu pai
falou do bom não tinha muita grana mas
ainda assim pensou vou fazer se essa
vontade da minha filha em nova york eu
chego minha prima me recebe e hoje
estranho porque ela não me leva pra nova
iorque dos prédios e tudo mais a gente
comece pelo interior de nova york vai
vai vai
duas horas de viagem a gente vai pra rua
e viu que é um centro
sei lá duas horas mais ou menos de nova
york onde ela morava
não acham eu falei o que que é isso eu
vi pessoas vegetarianas que não comiam
carne pessoas que não fumavam pessoas
que não bebiam com as minhas amigas
fazem na escola eu fazia também já muito
precoce e aí que aconteceu naquele
ambiente é eu tomei um susto isso porque
aprimorava por lá que conheceu o marido
dela pela internet ele era o técnico do
ach técnico do ar condicionado e por
causa disso eu estava lá conhecendo guru
maio maguro mulher
isso me chamou muita atenção porque se
no colégio tinha tido um exemplo de
muitas freiras e eu admirava muito não
sei porque não sei se por causa da
fantasia
não sei se por causa da austeridade ou
de um caminho de devoção de novo aos 14
anos eu me vi confrontado com essa
realidade e de pessoas que adoravam é
seguro e geralmente eu tinha já registo
de alguns gurus homens eu acho que é
mais normal no nosso imaginário era
aquela mulher tão linda tão austera e
que influenciava tantas pessoas aqui me
chamou muita atenção porque pelo modo
diferente de vida como o mundo é diverso
e como as buscas são diferentes e isso
me tocou de maneira tão forte e eu
acredito como como é forte o sentido de
que a gente é sempre semente
unidade de acontecer a todo momento a
todo momento são sementes que são
plantadas em nós e muitas vezes a gente
não percebe a gente passa como
automático e neste momento dos 14 anos
com orgulho mas aquilo foi muito forte
pra mim aquela quantidade de pessoas
aquela beleza pelas pessoas pintadas e
todas pintadas e aquilo também me chamou
muito a atenção
passou a minha vida na hora de escolher
a profissão é claro que minha mãe me
lembrou daquela menina aqui escova em
que eu vivo na televisão narrando a
morte de tancredo eu não tive dúvidas
que era jornalismo que eu queria
escolher eu não tive muitas muitos
questionamentos sobre o que eu queria
fazer da minha vida e foi assim que eu
escolhi então jornalismo
eu só sei que eu terminei a faculdade e
e logo depois eu trabalhei um breve
tempo na tv globo e já fui para a rádio
cbn que é hoje uma das maiores empresas
de de jornalismo mesmo do país em termos
de credibilidade e aquilo tinha um peso
pra mim muito jovem 23 24 anos
e pra mim eu tinha que interpretar
aquele papel da mulher séria da mulher
do hard news
e aí muito cedo eu percebi que aquela
menina que gostava tanto da magia ali
atrás
eu não acho que ela se perdeu mas eu
acho que ela estava mais quietinha eu
estava experimentando em outros papéis e
um desses papéis era de ser jornalista
séria e traz as notícias pesadas que
traz a denúncia que traz o que é preciso
ser relatado nesta sociedade que a gente
vive como a gente entrar a notícia
informação hoje gente aquilo me trazia
um peso que não era só o peso do que eu
estava fazendo como eu estava encarando
a minha própria realidade até porque uma
das coisas que eu gosto muito ver na
minha vida que não é o que a gente faz é
sempre como a gente faz mas aquele
momento isso não era muito claro pra mim
e eu passei por um período de muita
aprovação interna porque estava muito
distante daquela menina enfrentada com a
guru mai daquela menina que gostava de
brincar não de boneca mas delas é a
própria heroína da própria história e
aquilo foi muito pesado pra mim e esse
causa interna é muito engraçado quando
caos de fora só reflete o caos que você
tem
dentro o que aconteceu o momento
fatídico 2006 queda do avião da tam em
que todas as equipes de reportagem foram
deslocados para cobrir esse evento
trágico que foi um luto para o país e
nem se diz para os jornalistas que lá
estavam em uma cobertura incessante que
a gente passou madrugadas e é claro que
num momento como esse você tem que
entrar no automático porque senão você
não aguenta você tem que ficar contando
o corpo um corpo mais dois corpos jamais
encontrados para relatar esse ofício do
jornalista e naquele período eu já
faltava no trabalho eu tinha dor de
cabeça tinha sinusite rinite tinha
bronquite tudo it que você pode imaginar
eu tinha porque eu não queria mais
aquilo e é claro que o meu corpo tão
saudável dentro de si tão sábio ele
estava me dizendo que não era aquilo que
eu devia fazer tudo eu fumava tomava
muito café e comia muito mal eu odiava
salada e não comer tomate
eu gostava de ir para o bar com os meus
amigos e conversar aquela coisa toda
só que ao mesmo tempo se tinha um lado
muito legal estar com as pessoas têm
outro muito pesado eu me sentia muito
pesada como se eu tivesse desviado do
meu caminho e nesse momento fatídico aí
aparecem os anjos porque eu sei que
minha vida é cercado dessa mais e aí vem
um anjo na minha vida que foi uma colega
uma amiga da rádio ela já tá muito mais
tempo eu tinha um ano e meio e cbn ela
já tinha um pouco mais e eu falei
fabíola
eu não aguento mais falar de morte eu
preciso falar de vida eu preciso falar
das coisas que eu gosto eu preciso falar
das coisas que eu acredito será que isso
é possível me ajuda e ela na hora em que
eu estava falando isso pra ela ela tinha
a mesma sensação é claro que por
caminhos diferentes mas tinha uma
sensação muito semelhante ela falou
pedra vamos falar de vida e aí numa
tarde linda como essa começa a manhã de
hoje
é a gente sentou para tomar um vinho
comum queijo ea gente cria um programa
se chama caminhos alternativos em que a
gente pensou em fazer o seguinte tá
vamos falar de caminhos alternativos mas
a gente não quer se esse padrão de
revista feminina que a gente tem até
hoje a gente quer passar pelas vivências
e colocar enxerga
coisas que acontecem qual é esse cheque
a minha experiência eu posso falar só
pelo que eu sinto não posso falar pra
você faça eu posso falar pra você
experimenta e é essa proposta que a
gente tinha de fazer um caminho
alternativo está mas não vence para a
cbn política economia onde é que vai
cabeça história
e aí é que eu só tenho confirmação da
minha vida como a mágica está presente
a gente foi para a direção de jornalismo
da rádio cbn conversar com a diretora
uma mulher
na hora ela olhou com apreensão a gente
apresentou esse programa pra ela
imediatamente depois da apresentação ela
tocou e ela perguntou pra gente quando a
gente grava o piloto
aí sim deu um frio na barriga porque
será que a gente a bancar aquilo que a
gente acreditava muito fácil a gente
acreditar na magia mas como é que é
construir essa imagem no dia a dia
porque eu acreditava na magia mas a
gente precisa construir e é por isso que
eu falo da integração de filosofia e
ação é uma dor é uma dor a gente
perceber que a gente está vivo mas a
gente pode construir a maravilha também
que está vivo a primeira vivência do
caminhos foi no dia do meu aniversário a
primeira reportagem ea gente vai falar
sobre a vida a ir ver da é a ciência da
altura de acordo com os indianos faz
parte da medicina tradicional indiana e
pé bem diferente do que a gente está
acostumado a ver hoje no ocidente ea
gente foi para as práticas de limpeza
orgânicas
vocês se lembram eu não comia uma folha
verde sequer eu fumava o que aconteceu
práticas orgânicas de limpeza
eu fui limpá muco do estômago do nariz
limpar o ouvido limpar as minhas
vísceras
essa é um pouco a idéia do euro vida da
limpeza interna e da limpeza externa e
nesse dia de prática fábio ligou o
gravador eu comecei a passar por tudo
ali pra mim aquilo foi muito familiar
é claro que eu preciso de alguma maneira
começar essa limpeza eu tô perturbada
existem caminho assim e é claro que o
meu veículo corpo é o único veículo onde
eu posso experimentar livro
experimentasse dar certo e aí eu comecei
até essas práticas para os caminhos
alternativos da rádio
eu comecei a trazer a minha vida e
comecei a praticar o mesmo e comecei a
procurar especialistas e eu comecei a
ver como era importante esse processo de
limpeza pra mim eu precisava me limpar
para me encontrar porque a minha pedra
bruta mágica tava lá a da menina que
queria essa mágica na vida porque é
claro que a gente só consegue
experiência no contraste se tenho a luz
ea sombra é ali que você consegue se
enxergar e pra mim isso foi ficando
muito nítido
eu fui pra ir venda em pouco depois eu
comecei a praticar ioga é eu não gostava
muito de grupos e os iogues né os
meditadores não ia por conta própria
mesmo experimentando até me encontrar e
depois de uns três meses dessas práticas
eu parei de comer carne mas eu não sou
nenhum tipo de ativista disso é só
porque eu realmente não sentia que fazer
bem pra mim e acho que esse senso de
refinamento que eu acho muito legal
quando eu converso com os ouvintes do
caminhos por eu mesma poder experimentar
não quero que nenhum médico venha me
contar o que eu tenho que sentir eu
quero sentir para poder compartilhar e
aí nesse caminho então eu comecei a
mudar minha alimentação procurei alguns
nutricionistas alguns médicos também
atlético que me trouxeram um leque de
possibilidades de auto cura e
autoconhecimento por meio da alimentação
comecei a comer de novo verdura comecei
a tirar do meu cardápio muitas coisas
que não me faziam bem e para mim ficou
muito claro como essa história da
alimentação
ela é fundamental na transformação para
eu me tornar um campo fértil para essa
pressa magia porque eu tinha dores eu
tinha dor de cabeça eu reclamava coisas
que eu vejo algumas pessoas ao meu redor
em outras empresas quando eu faço
palestras me contando tem horas que a
gente não tem motivação e o corpo grita
falando pra você presta atenção na sua
alma
presta atenção no que está fazendo a
gente precisa se integrar
é claro que são sinais são dicas e eu
digo pra vocês que ao longo de cinco
anos de caminhos alternativos e com
transformações pequenas transformações
difíceis eu fui reconstruindo aquela
magia que eu sabia que eu tinha e que é
tão bom diz
eu adoro as coincidências elas acontecem
todos os dias e é muito lindo de ver
isso acontecer eu acho que a minha vida
é muito especial e eu não tenho nenhum
fato tão drástico para relatar a não ser
como eu consigo observar eu treinasse
meu olhar pra conseguir observar um
milagre todo dia por isso que eu falei
da gratidão logo no começo de estar aqui
porque esse é um exercício que a gente
faz para poder estar presente e eu
repito para vocês pra mim o corpo e
alimentação é instrumento básico para a
gente recuperar essa magia ao longo do
caminho alternativo a gente entrevistou
muita gente espiritual pessoas mais
espirituais que eu já entrevistei não
tinha religião mas a espiritualidade
transbordava delas e eu via como essa
magia
era o que fazia a diferença é claro que
não é o que você faz ou como você faz
então como cada uma dessas pessoas
trazia magia para a vida delas é o que
me encantava e como usar o jornalismo
como álibi para poder estar perto dessas
pessoas e para reforçar a crença em mim
de que é possível viver a magia todo dia
e é isso que o treino porque não é fácil
quando todo mundo te diz 'não você
conseguir dizer sim há muito pouco tempo
entrevistei o físico marcelo gleiser
falando a respeito da espiritualidade
ele contava que um dia ele estava dando
uma entrevista numa rodoviária no fim de
ano falando sobre a questão de deus
e aí ele nessa área sempre ele consiga
começar a construir deus bom físico que
é e foi então que um homem na rodoviária
bem simples chegou pra ele falou assim
nossa gente já tem tão pouco até isso
você quer tirar de nós a sensação de
deus
ele tomou um choque isso ele contando é
muito lindo porque ele falou bom no
limite eu percebi que a ciência não é
capaz hoje de alimentar essa esperança e
essa fé que as pessoas têm e aí ele teve
um insight ele falou assim é preciso a
gente despertar nas crianças
logo cedo o encantamento pela ciência
o encantamento verdadeiro pela natureza
das co
não por uma fé dogmática não por má-fé
supersticiosa mas é porque a natureza é
tão incrível e tão maior do que nós e
não tem como a gente não se encantar
e aí isso também me montar essa minha
experiência com caminhos alternativos
que na verdade é a minha vida como eu
falei pra vocês jornalistas só como
álibi para poder falar que eu quero
entrevista você eu tenho entrevistado
muitas mulheres ultimamente e têm
relatado uma busca louca por esse
encontro esse encontro de quem eu sou
pra que eu sirvo o que eu faço dessa
minha vida que eu sei que é poderosa mas
o que eu faço sem referência e muitas
dessas mulheres abandonaram altos cargos
executivas com lindas carreiras para
tentarem se aproximar do que elas
realmente são
e aí um ponto importante não são os
altos cargos que a gente ocupa nas
empresas não é a quantidade de mulheres
que a gente vem altos cargos eu acho que
a nossa responsabilidade como mulher é
muito maior do que essa
a gente como mulher hoje a gente tem uma
responsabilidade de construir e desse a
liderança de uma sociedade mais saudável
de uma sociedade mais saudável e
conseqüentemente mais consciente em
busca do que da mágica você quer mágica
maior do que tem uma coisinha aqui
dentro da sua barriga
é um absurdo isso é muito mágico eu falo
isso porque estou tentando buscar essa
experiência agora eu fico refletindo
sobre isso e eu vejo como é importante
eu sei esse campo fértil como corpo
comumente como a alma é claro que eu não
sou perfeita mas eu quero me cercar de
boas maçãs 3 61 boa maçã também eu volto
pra uma última história e um foi um dos
meus últimos entrevistados cv com o
masculino eo feminino é tão importante
eu não quero competir com o homem e não
quero tirar o seu lugar eu quero estar
junto com você pra gente construir junto
entender juntos quais são os nossos
papéis
um dos meus últimos entrevistados no
caminhos alternativos foi o professor
william ury
ele criou em raiva do departamento de
mediação de conflito
esse homem já teve em chechênia mediano
conflito com a rússia afeganistão síria
venezuela enfim os maiores conflitos
insolúveis do planeta e ele virou pra
mim e falou assim pétrea
eu tenho percebido que muitas vezes na
resolução de conflitos insolúveis
muitas vezes uma história funciona como
cura
e aí eu volto pra gente tá liderança de
uma sociedade mais saudável mais
consciente mais mágica qual caminho pra
isso
talvez o caminho pra isso a gente se
voltar para as nossas próprias histórias
descobrir onde está a mágica nela e
voltar a viver essa mágica todos os dias
da nossa vida